today we have a very special guest
joining us he stars in the hit series
fear
the walking dead and you can catch him
in the upcoming netflix film ma rainey's
black bottom
it is going to be epic and he also knows
how to mix up a mean cocktail that's
right
bottomless brunch on amc anyone
please welcome coleman domingo
hello how are you drew
don't mind if i do call men thank you
samia darling
oh my gosh i'm so excited that you're
here on the show
you have so many fans here and a
wonderful career
and fun fact you uh
were given or nominated for a barrymore
award
yes i was actually oh yeah yes your
namesake so we're we're already
connected my friend we've been connected
for many years and you had no idea i was
so excited about that detail and by the
way they're all
alcoholics so this is perfect
of course cheers this is just apropos
cheers i made
i decided to make a a black manhattan
which is actually
a manhattan you know with bourbon and um
bitters but
you swap out the sweet vermouth for
amaro
which is uh italian digest thief it's
good for the belly but it's like herbal
and
it's really warm and cozy and makes you
feel like a nice fall blanket
anything like jagermeister exactly
oh the cinnamon oh my god
what is on the rim of the glass there's
a little cinnamon there right
oh gosh it's so aromatic
isn't it beautiful oh it's just
beautiful
now you started doing bottomless brunch
on amc
which is such a fun show and by the way
like gardening goals
oh my god well you know the pandemic had
me in the garden i was doing things that
i'd never done before i was uh
digging trying to grow things and then i
was um i wanted to create a show
uh which was bringing people together
very similar to your show just like you
know
i think we're people who like to bring
people together and spread some joy
and light in the world so that's what
bottomless bunch of coleman's is all
about it's
it's on amc it's streaming now on
amc.com and it's just it's just fun i
bring people together like common
and yaya dual mateen and nissi nash
uh julia styles you name it you never
know who's gonna show up no it's so
great i've
and also can you please tell us about ma
rainey's black bottom because
sorry is that the title okay um
all of a sudden i panicked um i've been
watching the trailers
this is a very very important film
it's chadwick boseman's last film it's
viola
davis it's directed by george c wolfe it
is going to come out to netflix in the
end of december
can you tell us about it absolutely my
rainey's black bottom as
is it takes place on one hot
um afternoon with jazz musicians um
my rainey's recording in this session up
in chicago in 1920s
and it's basically just trying to get
through the day and it's a russell
about ideologies about what it is to be
black in america
what it is to be an artist um it's
passionate it really tells the story of
ma rainey who was
one of the first openly gay uh jazz
musicians um
and in her band chad bozeman and i we
play
members of the band i'm the band leader
and uh we wrestle
and we literally we wrestle we wrestle
we fight we try to uh
find a new way of living and it's an
august wilson play who did
fences it's produced by denzel
washington i'm very excited for this
coleman this went by so fast i can't
thank you enough for being here
you are such a privilege to hang out
with drink with
and you deserve all the awards in the
world thank you so much we'll be looking
out for your important new film
and celebrating you with bottomless
brunches and fear the walking dead on
amc
thank you coleman take care good to see
[Music]
you
you